hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode for
video we finally got our best episode we
found out what she's been doing since
she got grabbed it was a little bit like
the governor episode from season four
well we found out what he did after the
season 3 finale
although the arc of the episode was
vastly different it also gave us some
clues as to who that was with Daryl at
the end of episode 3 click reminder new
round of the giveaway starts right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet starting
with top five moments number 5 Beth is
Rick from Season one the episode starts
pretty much the same way episode 1 from
season 1 starts she just shoots up in
bed doesn't know where she is
Rick made it out of that Hospital Beth
not so much but it does become about
them adjusting to their new environment
rick has to learn all about the
apocalypse Beth has to learn all about
the world of the hospital based on the
shot of the window it pretty much looks
like we're back in Atlanta that's one of
the biggest cities near where they're at
Scott Gimple did tease that we would see
some old locations in new ways this
seems like what he was talking about
without going into crazy spoilers based
on the amount of time that they spent
filming they're like how late in the
year
it looks like Beth is gonna be there for
a little while so she'll have her own
storyline apart from everyone else
number 4 welcome to the hospital you
give back what you take sounds like a
very simple economy doesn't quite work
out that way Beth starts to meet all the
new people none of them seem
particularly friendly with the exception
to Noah to me it seemed like just
another version of Woodbury it's just
that the governor is wearing a badge
that lady cop just seems every bit as
crazy though the tour is pretty fun
especially that elevator shaft which
they later paid off whenever they shimmy
down it it reminded me a little bit of
the trash compactor from Star Wars with
little Walker die agonize floating
around at the bottom the lady cop that's
in charge her name is dawn Lerner she
explains what's going on
don't view this as a sentence you have
to pay off what you've taken like all
the care that she received she has to
pay off by doing work really it's just
like another version of the prison it's
funny Beth leaves one prison and falls
into another of all the places that she
could have landed this is probably
better than terminus though number three
Beth vs. officer McCrae P so in addition
to introducing her to the grossest
lollypop ever officer rape provides the
call to action that Beth needs
he's the hurdle that she has to jump
over before she can escape it's like her
dragon to slay in the episode which she
of course does wonderfully I was kind of
hoping that they push him down the
elevator shaft though that was my only
disappointment the woman that turned
into a walker that killed him that's
Keyshia Castle huge she's also playing a
bar of Santa and Game of Thrones Season
5 so it was just the nice little thing
there if she wasn't gonna get revenge on
Walking Dead I knew she'd get it on Game
of Thrones as a sand snake I also
thought it was nice that they let Beth
give him death by lollipop but smashing
that jar on his head how's that for
gross lollipops in terms of challenges
that they could have presented Beth with
I felt like they could have made a
better choice than turning Gorman into
officer McCrae pea that would probably
go down as my biggest complaint against
the episode is that in providing
challenges for a teenage girl to get
over her sexuality doesn't have to be
one of them or an attack on her
sexuality
I feel like Beth is just gonna go the
rest of her life without ever having sex
all of her boyfriends have died and now
everyone's just trying to rape her you
can let me know if you agree but do you
think that they needed to include the
rape in the episode I feel like there
were a number of other ways that they
could have challenged her like he could
have just tried to push her down the
elevator shaft number two Beth versus
officer learner that's the lady cop and
eventually we learned she is every bit
as nutty as every villain that we've
seen on the show even though officer
McCrae P was the obvious villain she's
the big bad because she is flat-out
nutty Beth knew what officer rape wanted
rape and lollipops it's really hard to
predict crazy people's behavior though
so she's gonna have to learn how to deal
with learner the doctor tries to justify
things by saying as bad as it is up here
it's better than down there I'm sure
that Keisha castle Hughes would not
agree with that she actually wanted to
die they had to force her to let them
cut her arm off the way they let things
between Beth and Lerner's a little
ambiguous - they're just gonna be
butting heads until Beth gets out based
on the in credits scene with Carol it
seems like that's not gonna be for a
while like she's gonna have to change
her plan
I like the tease that her plan was
basically just stab everyone at the end
starting with dr. Eugene who essentially
we learned is basically the Eugene of
the hospital and my number one WTF
moment
Beth helps no escape this was really the
moment of Beth's self-actualization she
takes one for the team so that Noah can
escape and she takes down a walker
Hardcore in the process it was a nice
callback to learners comments that out
there you're nothing you're somebody's
burden Beth calls [ __ ] on it all and
helps her friend escape that's why I
think that he's the person who's with
Daryl in the bushes I think whenever
Daryl walks out whichever next episode
he appears in it's gonna be Noah behind
him he and Carol went to look for Beth
Carol showed up in the hospital at the
end that means that Daryl was nearby
during their escape attempt so Noah's
probably going to explain what's going
on with Beth or hopefully he will thus
we find our mid-season finale battle I
think that the survivors Rick and the
survivors are gonna go and try and get
Beth and Carol there have been a lot of
people trying to post potentially
spoilery things about that so if you
have any spoilery theories just be sure
to use spoiler tags in the comments a
lot of people are theorizing that
someone might die like a main cast
member
just please use photo tags if you want
to talk about that let me know though
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and what do you think is gonna
happen with Carol now clearly Beth is
gonna have to alter her escape plan she
was just gonna stab everyone and play it
by ear but now that Carol's there
hopefully she'll be able to help overall
I gave the episode a solid b-plus I know
a lot of people aren't huge fans of
Beth's character but I actually thought
it was really good I thought it was a
good call to action we saw a little bit
of that during the Daryl episodes last
season when she was just kind of
starting to grow up a little bit
she called [ __ ] on Daryl now she's
calling [ __ ] on everyone at the
hospital I think the officer Lerner
character she's actually played by
Christine woods is a really nice twist
on like a Rik governor person clearly
she's crazy
and she seems to be just plucking people
at random who she thinks can help them
off the street I think the real question
now is what is Beth gonna do with Carol
I do think that Carol is gonna wake up I
don't think she's gonna be in a coma or
anything
officer McRae pee is gone but that
doesn't mean there aren't other awful
people working for a learner so I don't
think that Carol is just gonna be able
to pistol-whip them all there is a
theory that Carol intentionally allowed
herself to be found by the group I don't
think that we're gonna learn about that
till we see Daryl again in an episode
hopefully he'll explain what's going on
visually there are a lotta nice
callbacks to previous episodes like the
first episode with Rick waking up in the
hospital bed the first episode of season
3 where they cut Herschel's leg off when
they were lowering down in the elevator
shaft it was also a little bit like
Glenn getting lured in the well during
season two I like the way they're able
to automatically call back to previous
episodes but do it in really new
interest
waise the big thing now is what are the
consequence is gonna be for Beth they
are definitely gonna make her pay for
killing Gorman and for helping no escape
I think that Carroll arriving woke her
up just a little bit so I do think
she'll have her wits about her just a
little bit better she'll be a little bit
more crossbow Beth versus Hershel's farm
Beth I also like that she realizes the
doctors a total coward that's just one
more person that doesn't have any power
over her anymore
I know I called him the Eugene but he
might end up turning into a Bob type
character you know someone with a really
weak Constitution who becomes someone
much stronger or he could just take a
trip down the elevator shaft
all in all great episode love the new
location can't wait to see how things
develop at the hospital especially now
that Carole's there next week is gonna
be a DC episode it'll be all Abraham's
group so be sure to subscribe to get my
video I'm also posting a Q&A for this
tomorrow let me know if you agree though
do you think that the hospital is gonna
be a battle for the mid-season finale do
you feel like the survivors are gonna go
and that's going to be like their next
big conflict in the meantime you can
click here for my Q&A video I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here for my episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high five and I'll see you guys
tomorrow